[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's true
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my gosh we're back
[Applause]
and welcome back to the break room this
is our daily show that keeps you updated
on what's going on in nerd news from our
very own break room yes this is our
break room here at new rockstar stations
you had a secret location on the moon
and we are broadcasting live right now
this isn't pre-recorded don't get it
twisted this is the realness this is
live it's happening right here i just
put my hand in water it must be real
whoa
i just lost it
uh we got a great show for you today uh
we're gonna be of course making our moon
night final predictions for that finale
that's coming at midnight i know you're
all staying up late to watch it uh we're
gonna talk about kevin feige speaking
truth to power in the multiverse uh and
one of us finally is gonna get canceled
yeah it's about time uh who's gonna get
cancelled well it might be me brandon
barrack it could be zach huddleston
hello great to be here and thank you for
all the love from all the audience
yesterday with all the lovely comments
about everybody in the show we certainly
appreciate it we also have tommy
bachdoll here with us can't cancel
someone who doesn't exist
and these fingerprints have been burnt
off my hands for over 20 years
so go ahead and try and by the way the
answer is yes
my mom does think i look good in this
day
doesn't he look great in the jacket
folks uh and of course we have jessica
clements here as well let her know you
can't cancel the chancellor wait whoa
can't cancel
who cancels the cancelman uh yeah we we
do we do have an exciting show for you
today uh and we are glad you are all
there in the chat right now we
appreciated you being there yesterday we
had some very fine people in the chat
sending out some great super chats uh we
appreciated it and we hope you do it
again today we also have a swear jar now
this is how this works uh we're not
allowed to curse on this show or the
government will shut us down uh or give
us a very hefty thing a lot of you did
point out that the fcc does not control
youtube that's not the government we're
talking about yeah we're talking about
the shadow government yeah the reptile
government okay this is the lizard
people yeah these are the lizard people
they have very hefty fines that they'll
give us
but if we raise enough money in our tip
jar we can unleash a few swears here and
there uh you can also send super chats
now i've been told to make this very
clear
that the super chance and the tip jar
are separate things okay
uh
if you do exclamation point rules uh
it'll give you some real rules if you do
exclamation point tip it'll give you
some tips on how to tip or exclamation
point don't i don't know put an
exclamation point before everything you
say in the chat yeah let's crash the
system let's see what we can do when we
do exclamation point tips why don't we
give you a tip
advice if you will
how many people that's too much to talk
about
i think a simple way to remember is if
you donate to the swear jar that's a
reward if you donate to the regular tip
jar that's so i can get more jackets we
gotta get tommy morning and i need every
color of easter i need some like light
pink yeah they're always gonna be a
light a pastel
but tommy just won't let it go easter
never ends for me it never ends for him
uh but yeah throw your questions in chat
we'll get to them at the end of the show
uh there's gonna be polls going on the
chat we we love that you're out there we
love interacting with you uh and we're
going to have a great time today as we
do every day here in the break room and
we're going to talk about moon night i
promise we got so many predictions for
the finale but we should do some
headlines yes every every break room
we're going to begin with a sick ass
graphic you just saw it yeah
nine times out of ten i will talk over
it because i will forget that
graphic thank you uh producer john but
we're gonna cover the news of the day
the the things in the nerdy zeitgeist
that you want to know about uh like
today there's some stranger things uh
news they revealed some character
posters on twitter
john can you look at these
characters our three adult characters we
got joyce we got hopper we got murray
hopper looks like stephen amell age
i mean
why is murray there
we can only assume he's gonna be gonna
play a big part in this season maybe
well he's like the link right he's the
one that he found
right like there was the um
uh they this was back maybe 2020 that
there was like a voicemail you could
call and you would hear murray's voice
joyce i just found out something about
rush or something something yeah
google it um anyways i bet we get
another round of posters for the kids uh
oh yeah definitely can i even call them
kids anymore no they're in high school
35 year olds that are playing children
on that show now yeah uh we also got
some news uh today this is kind of
exciting
viola davis this actually just broke
just about an hour ago viola davis is in
talks with hbo max to star in a
peacemaker spin-off
uh with what's her character's name
amanda waller right reprising her role
uh we saw her a little bit in the
peacemaker series and of course like
spoiler warning her daughter played a
big role in that uh the the amanda
waller's daughter not viola davis
daughter i don't believe those actors
are related um so that'd be cool because
i mean like a nice way of like building
out that suicide squad universe right
like is it also is it also going to be
run by james gunn
well i don't know if we know that yet
but it should right i mean
he was in charge of the original
peacemaker so he might want his hands to
it seems this is like the batman model
right they had the suicide squad movie
yes oh yeah one spin off and now a spin
off of the spin-off like yes well good
god the guy seems to love doing that
didn't he he had some quote like i could
make a series about everything yeah
oh if the cgi budget wouldn't be like
through the roof you know they do i want
to see them meet those kids yeah yeah
they're talking about them eating kids
eating you guys like corella killed the
dogs and like weasley okay
um in marvel news uh ms marvel the
upcoming uh series is getting a
theatrical release in pakistan which
that's cool on a couple levels first off
the reason they're doing it is there is
no disney plus in pakistan yet so the
only way they'd be able to see this is
through some other kind of distribution
deal or why not put it out in theaters
it's going to be split into three
kind of sessions of two episodes each
it's really cool we were talking about
this wouldn't it be cool if you could if
you could have gone to see like on
division or loki kind of in their
entirety yes in a theater yeah i don't
know how the timeline for uh miss marvel
will but i feel like it will somehow
like the last few episodes will line up
with our release of the episodes so
there's not too many spoilers but i'm
like yeah i would have rather just
watched all of wanda vision within like
three weeks like that would have been
really nice and like on a big screen
so fun so fun series are actually very
fun on like giant screens yeah i'm doing
it um and then uh other marvel news uh
black panthers deny guerrera uh okoye
from the black panther film uh
was that the met gala last night which
that's that ridiculous uh thing like the
lizard people all the celebrity as you
keep saying you keep pushing your lizard
people
that will not commit to because
i stopped here jeffrey
jessica stop bringing them i don't want
us to desecrate the uh a very important
event that is the met gala if we can
please give it the gravity and the
gravitas
you turn into a different person first
of all it's rare that you can get all of
those baseball players in one room
okay you get everyone you you get the
eight you're thinking of the mets gala
yes you get all the 86 cocaine meth
together with the 83 alcoholic mets you
get bobby bonilla yeah that's right
bobby both still getting a paycheck from
his right every year uh no the met gala
where all the celebrities go and they've
got fancy outfits on uh uh she was
interviewed on the red carpet and of
course they asked her about the upcoming
black panther sequel and uh and
specifically about chadwick boseman
which bless her heart i don't think she
showed up to this event ready to answer
a lot of in-depth questions about this
movie she was she was looking great
everybody's just there to show off the
great outfits and she's getting asked
like in canon questions from some
interviewer yeah um but uh we actually
have the clip of the interview
listen we we we poured everything we had
into it and you'll you'll we hope that
you you experience that and that it
resonates for everybody the way it does
for us it does it tells a
it tells a
it tells a very hard
heart-wrenching story and that is all i
can say
tribute to chadwick
uh
i think i think i think beautifully and
i'm very thankful for how
uh our amazing director writer um
handled that
and um you know it's all about him it's
all it's all about and for for all of us
it's all an outpouring to to love and to
uh to honor him oh uh
i love that and again i'll preface this
to give her
credit she was going off the cuff there
that was kind of a scripted line so when
she says it's all about
chadwick and his character i don't know
that that necessarily means the plot is
about that or whatever maybe making of
the film is it tribute to him or
whatever uh we don't really know
anything about the plot of that movie or
how they're going to handle any of it
but that that was a nice quote i feel so
it's it seemed i would be so bad at
making sure my words were right and she
i feel bad that she like she's like
started her way through it but it's like
hey you did it also you're not kevin
feige you're not trained to like jump
hurdles from these reporters at the met
gala not asking about your outfit you
just spent four and a half hours in hair
and makeup and like uh you know trying
not to wrinkle your fancy gown and now
you're getting asked questions about
this movie that you're probably not
allowed to answer uh credit to you she
was very composed and did a great job
jessica before you move on i do have to
we have a very important contribution in
the chat my boy mark and gave us ten
dollars and said go bills baby
go bills
go buffalo bills
you know what i'm saying hey i'm not i'm
not uh embarrassed to admit uh bills of
the official nfl team of the break room
yeah i don't think you know you know new
rock stars has made an effort to
distance themselves
from the buffalo bills but the break
room this is bill's mafia baby yeah in
fact this table somebody's gonna i'm
going through it at our hundredth
episode we can't afford new tables i
never know it's okay
this is how not into sports i am every
time someone says go bills and you say
buffalo bills i'm immediately like they
want to wear our skin why are we rooting
this out i don't do that you don't do
that you don't compare them to that
that's not what it's about from seattle
we're the seahawks
okay you didn't have to make fun of me
segway us into this you have no
quarterback
oh come on okay now now we're truly in
the weeds i've lost everybody okay we're
talking positions
uh in the nfl my heart just fell out of
my butt how dare you keep going well
jessica you um you've got some moonlight
content yeah i do i do i do you guys uh
moon knight artist greg smallwood shared
a great and inspiring piece he made
mirroring the art for his his lemire and
bel-air
belair
moon knight number two issue
uh there it is that art is inspired by
the show but it also mimics their
original art for their number two issue
which is i just think it's great that
him and jeremy slater on twitter going
back and forth being like you inspired
me and it's like no you inspired me
that is a great looking thing it's so it
looks like the living tribunal
in the corner of it i don't know if
everyone can see it but it was like it's
so it's mark's face and then arthur
harrow and it's just perfectly ethan
hawk to the left or right and i just i
love it it's so beautiful if they made
that into a poster i'd buy it
immediately kind of like lungs at the
top oh that couldn't it was like pink i
don't know i don't know i don't know
this is the this is a part of moon
knight that i'm also very excited about
and also angry about
bushman was supposed to be the original
villain in moon knight jeremy slater
said in an interview that bushman was
supposed to be the original villain in
moon knight and i don't know about you
guys but i have been saying bushman is
coming butchman is coming yeah and you
have been saying that a
doing
lot
for years hey jessica i'm about to go on
a run do you want bushman's coming
but i he is and the thing is okay so uh
for those that don't know bushman was a
part of the mercenary team that uh mark
was on and when he was going to rob the
gold who is now layla and her dad were
like no and he was like i'm going to
murder them senselessly mark tried to
defend them and got almost beat halfway
to death while buschmann killed the dad
so that plot line could still live
because what we know is that he crawled
halfway to death to konshu statue that
doesn't mean that like
he didn't get beat halfway to death by
bushmen so buschmann could still be
there but he did go further on in the
interview saying that uh bushman was
supposed to be possessed by an egyptian
god and there was supposed to be a giant
adjective oh
which i don't think we're gonna get yeah
yeah i don't think we'll see any bush
but now at this point and tease this is
gonna come back late at least in one of
my predictions of the finale mr bushman
is going to make an appearance whoa
it's still possible and i'm not oh look
at that face
that has an evil cut away otherwise the
cameras would all break well we were
getting too many tips let's get into it
it's our main topic today let's talk
about the moon night finale yeah uh it
premieres tonight at midnight on the the
west coast east coast three 3 a.m i'm
gonna have to stay up real late tonight
yeah yeah if you're if you're in europe
wake up nice and early in the morning
and watch it uh oh yeah but yeah we're
very excited we've got we've made some
final predictions for this episode
uh we don't know we got one episode left
they gotta wrap up some of these story
lines i feel like there's still so much
that i don't understand about the show
about what's going on but let's make our
final predictions right here right now
in the break room all right the first
prediction i'm gonna ask for everyone to
make is what mcu property do you think
they're gonna tie in in this last
episode if any if any are they going to
lash it on to something upcoming
upcoming something that's already
happened in the past also everybody in
the chat also throw out your suggestions
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah i want to see how many of you
agree with me yeah
and this is mainly out of me really
wanting this i want it to be blade oh i
want it to be blade we have enough time
to still keep ramping that up i think
with the end of uh eternals great little
subtle part keep making it a little
subtle keep doing little subtle pieces
until it comes just a little voice in
the background yeah and then turn around
just do little little pieces you can
keep sprinkling those into those kind of
like movies and
tv shows sprinkle sprinkle little blade
what about you tommy oh what mcu
property will tie in hmm what could it
be i think it'll be the eternals the
eternal they're going back yeah the
internals
it's like they're like the elevator and
willy wonka it goes up way sideways back
ways down
it could still be forward right because
there's a couple of eternals no all the
eternals are off planet now well this is
what i'm saying though i think there's
maybe it might be in a flashback
but we're dealing with lowercase g gods
here right we got egyptian gods we got
eternals that were mistaken for gods or
sometimes true uh uh
depicted as gods and art so i have a
feeling that there may be an element of
like the uh mark and layla are going to
make so much noise and are the herald
they're going to get the attention of
the eternals the eternals that are not
currently being
suspended in space or whatever it
happened at the end of that movie and i
just think we might get like maybe a
kumal nanjiani okay
you know okay yeah
what about you zach well here's what i'm
gonna say and this is already kind of
going off of that we've seen some blade
cameos i think this is going to tie in
with
secret invasion okay all right because
that means we see a skrull show up i
don't know if we see some other hint
right like there was a secret invasion
tie-in in one division obviously or we
we assume with the scroll agent showing
up there near the end also weirdly
we don't know a lot about the secret
invasion show but like people are hype
for it any time we cover secret invasion
stuff on the channel like it does really
well i think like they could do just a
slow trickle of information kind of
building out what if secret invasion is
almost the end game of these disney plus
series i could see that i could see that
i i ride i write for that well those are
some great predictions everybody but i'm
afraid they're wrong uh they're
absolutely wrong uh here's what marvel
italian is gonna exist for the mcu with
moon knight it's gonna be black panther
they're gonna tie in black panther we're
in egypt we're in africa right there's
egyptian gods and this we'll get i'll
get into this one a little bit more but
it's going to be black panther i think
will be the tie-in i love it i love it
it's coming out later this year why not
um
do you see everybody else's they said
thor 4 ghost rider gore werewolf by
knight kang
i would like ghost riders oh
they show the dunes and you hear a
motorcycle
the great thing about doing ghost rider
you could have him in the flaming skull
and they don't even have to have a
catheter
what do you want that's true and then
off screen you hear blade and he's like
who the [ __ ] is that
[Music]
now we all have to put our fingers in
your water yeah
i'll drink the finger water okay second
prediction i need everyone to make uh uh
who is gonna resurrect mark assuming he
gets resurrected can we go in the
opposite direction yeah we can go in the
operation okay i'll start here this one
and first off i want to shout out my
buddy uh mark and in there in the chat
yeah he says uh this one's for you zach
way to let him know what's up i don't
know what i'm letting them know what's
going on
okay
yes oh yeah go bills he gave two
donations one just because he wanted to
let you know he appreciated you and
that's what you get with the bill's
mafia the bills make me want to shout
yes buffalo bill tommy never doesn't get
this hype for anything
i don't think parody songs
improvises and the buffalo bill um okay
who will resurrect mark i'm gonna go out
on a limb
i think uh
layla
as the avatar of kanchu
that's wow i think i think maybe she's
not the permanent this is a little bit
of michelle williams and venom you know
what i mean element here of like he
temporarily possesses her somehow she
uses that spirit to resurrect him then
like country goes back to mark stephen
uh jake whatever whatever okay venom too
now on hulu by the way for those of you
oh okay yeah great great in between a
handmade tail uh episodes you can snap
hit girl from plainview with a venom two
chaser and then wrap it up with some
handmade towels then take a long walk
into the ocean uh that would be my ideal
tuesday night because that's what day it
is tuesday because this is live live
tommy beck told who is resurrecting mark
in this final episode my lord and savior
jesus christ oh okay no take off that
jacket has gone through your head
[Laughter]
on a hill oh there you go
no uh i think it's gonna be arthur
harrow whoa
being forced to do it whoa by layla
laila's going to have more oh aren't
your harrow over a barrel
layla's going to be like bring him back
can arthur harold like
he ingest souls right can he like barf
that's what i'm thinking is we're going
to learn that like he can he's going to
pull him out of that like a david blaine
trick where he's parked maybe he has to
do a swap he's got to give himself up to
bring back
only one may live while the other must
die oh okay okay what about you jessica
who is resurrecting mark i think
it's also laila oh but i really wanted
to be terror what i wanted to be i want
her to like be like watching all the
stuff happening and be like i need to i
need to get involved i need to get
involved and while layla's crying over
mark's body she like jumps in and she's
like i can restore him and so i don't i
don't hate that idea i mean i am db
which is not always 100 accurate they
did say we'd see the actress who plays
towerette the voice credited for three
episodes
so we should see her again in this
episode i don't know didn't we get like
a cool picture of her like didn't she
wear like a mocap i think she held
the head maybe because a lot of times uh
eric voss actually tweeted this like
though sometimes the actors will be on
chat where i don't i don't know i said a
name and it immediately left my brain uh
i wish all the error hosted this show
there i did the comment for you guys
okay
i did it for you yeah i would like to
show better if it was just eric
he did we did see her on set like
holding the head which was like very
elaborate it wasn't just a cardboard
cutout like i think they made like a
nice heavy model of it it was a cute
little head my my prediction
would you stop it sorry sorry brandon
sorry my prediction for who's gonna
resurrect mark uh and this ties back to
my mcu tie-in
bast the goddess back
i think maybe she's been frozen in a new
shopkin for a while panther god yeah and
she will get released and she's just
gonna she's not gonna make mark black
panther or anything like that but she's
gonna be like hey you're doing good work
out there get back out there get off the
bench you just used um you you labeled
bass as a as a female character is that
confirmed is she like a female well the
way i feel like the way they've talked
about i thought in black panther he
referred her yeah i think they okay they
do say she uh and i think she's usually
and i think in the comics she's usually
represented as feminine so
i'm gonna go with that yeah uh because
all women are god
that's right
god is a woman yeah it's true uh so yeah
that's that's my prediction there okay
another prediction i need you to mention
we got more predictions everybody this
is the marvel show uh-huh what's the
twist oh i like that this is not our
final prediction there's one there's
this and one more yeah yeah
i'll go um i'll go first this time uh i
think the twist is going to be we're
going to find out that jake
was once always and forever the original
he's the alpha personality jake
alpha person and mark and steven are
both wow
fresh personalities jake was the og and
maybe this whole brother drowning thing
i don't know if it's real or not or if
it was like a manipulation of kanchu but
i think we're going to find out that
jake was always the original
wow that's right
that prediction made me want to change
my mind well it's too late
john twins no no okay i'll say two for
next but
i think my what's the twist moment is um
john pull it up because i just forgot
what it was
oh
no no twist oh no no my twist was konshu
is jake oh so in the comics there is
this really great scene that um when
mark is coming to terms with like
everything he's like breaking the skull
of konshu konshu is himself and i think
it goes deeper than that where konchu
was actually jake and i think konshu has
just been like
you weren't doing your job right so i
had to like take a part of your mind
that's already like having a hard time
and just become you
so i think consciousness
uh what about you tommy what's your
twist
i my twist is that i don't think
anything that we have seen
so far
in the show has been actual reality this
show i think on this show
on moonlight that's all real that's a
documentary
oh no
sex sex ascending uh
you know i think that
uh all of uh episode 6 will reveal that
everything that has happened even the
scenes involving layla and the forger
have all been in the mind of another
person okay all of the snow globe insane
elsewhere a reference from 1984. oh it's
been a lot of our viewers
totally understand i think my mom is
watching she'll get it i think my dad
will watch at some point i don't know he
doesn't really he's not a fan of my work
but uh
i think so i think and i think that
person will be revealed and i don't know
that it's jake lockley you're all in
this jake lockley train obsessed with
this jake lockley maybe it's someone
else okay maybe it's a different
personality maybe it's former buffalo
bill's linebacker daryl talley
you know what it's sure not a new york
jet i'll tell you that okay jets don't
have the balls
okay okay this thing's a jet gala
[Laughter]
my prediction for the twist okay
i think mark
was bushman oh
mark was the killed all those people
right maybe his injuries when he gets
possessed by khanshu were people
fighting back always slaughtering them
right maybe he's maybe he was lying to
her when he said that you know bushman
was the leader and whatever i feel like
they made a point of never showing us
bushmen bushman's body anything like
that bushman also
sounds like a fake name yeah sounds like
he looked at the bottom of a mug and it
said bushman industries and he's like
that's who made me do it bushman you
know what i mean um a little usual
suspect
jose huh yes i think i think either mark
is literally bushman or bushman is one
of the alters or
he was the actual bad guy in that
scenario and maybe the get part of that
was the guilt drove him to konchu or
whatever okay uh madness arcade i'm
sorry i'm going down i'm not wearing my
glasses madness arcade said what if
there's no jake what if the third altar
is randall it's obvious that mark took
aspects from his life to create alters
like with stephen so what
if so what if what is grief his grief
over randall's death was so i can't read
the rest dawson
but i think
the younger brother yeah the younger
brother which i really like
i
love that theory madness arcade that's a
great theory i would love to see that
i'd love to hang out in a madness arcade
oh these references are going great with
chat they're loving it there's someone
in chat that said not again with the bad
jokes
i'm sorry have we already uh reached the
field for bad jokes yeah wait is this
yeah cause this welt runs dude i got bad
news the tip jar ain't filling up but
the bad joke jar
is got its capacity our cup overflow
with bad jokes we've got one more
prediction we need to make uh are we
gonna see our our baby boy stephen again
in the finale or is he just dust in the
wind just kidding
so aptly said wow i will tell you i
think i think we will see so
i think we will see stephen in the
finale but in a post-credits sequence i
think they're gonna go the whole time
without it and then the post credits uh
will be at like a coffee shop and
someone will say i got a macchiato for
stephen and then
this gate isn't it's my mom
that
um i simply say yes but in a memory
it'll be a core book you'll see him but
he's not like a lot yeah it's like a
flashback um well you know as phil
collins lead singer of genesis said uh
in the album no jacket required i don't
care anymore
uh don't care
looks like there is a little jackpot
required one jacket required baby and
it's on sale
uh no uh yes stephen stephen will
stephen will appear they'll appear early
on and everyone will have to they'll all
breathe a sigh of relief because their
favorite character will be oh this will
be like we come right into the episode
he's like oh i'm fine yeah he's just
gonna come out of the scene and be like
oh
am i i'm gonna be the only one i think
no no i think we get no idea also i like
how um to make the reverence even older
you referenced phil collins as the lead
singer of genesis not even his later
solo as phil collins that was the point
it's time for mandatory fun
that camera needs to do that every time
for mandatory fun the whipped cream yeah
the whip really quick
that's right it's mandatory fun you
remember the
made
segment
nation believe in love again and it's
back and it's going to be back every day
and that's where i make my friends my
three best friends join me in some
non-optional fun that's right you want
to opt out of this fun too man it's
mandatory play the graphic they already
played the great
there it is
i well some people need to see it twice
because they're visual learners like me
and guess what today we're canceling mf
first and i would have said the full
thing but y'all ain't filling up the tip
jar a little stingy with the tips today
for the swears oh yesterday was fun
premiere
empty the pockets today no the swear jar
might as well be a penny job you're
coming you can't turn heel on pictures
all right i want each of you listen this
is what we're doing mandatory fun they
said to make sure we're very clear what
the segment is this segment is where for
what's in this show i get to take things
off the rails okay i've practically been
an altar boy for the rest of the show
i've barely made it about me once but
this time we're going to talk about
mandatory fun we're going to talk about
moon night okay keeping it all in the
world of kanchu and the gang okay i like
it the khanshu crew look where the
donations are going
you guys you're reprimanded you're not
feeling like you have
the audience really pays off yeah and by
the way that shirt looks bad on you
i wouldn't date you if you begged me to
uh okay uh anyway so i want you guys to
give me your most controversial moon
night takes and at the end we're gonna
let the uh stingy people in the chat
decide who is the most controversial and
who's canceled okay and these are these
are takes that was cancelled yeah yeah
these are fine
moon knight takes these are our takes
not things about the show that should be
cancelled right which i mean there are a
few uh
so these are takes uh and i i don't need
the prompter to go up it's no problem
you can just leave it there
i don't know when you're gonna stop
these are our most common acts on most
controversial boondigs
and then the viewers will vote on which
one of us is canceled now everyone
remain calm which one of you is brave
enough to go first
[Music]
doesn't say attack the audience
and you keep doing it it's like which
viewers
hold on which one of us is cancelled
brandon you should i'll go first i'll go
first you got a cookie okay i got i got
one for you
hey
hey moon knight
the gods magic sucks okay that little
white wispy magic
that osiris just barely moves his little
fingies and it's white we love the
bright colors of magic in the mcu you
went with white boring bland also these
avatars give them some bling give them
yeah they're just wearing they're
wearing street clothes put them in some
goose i want to see god he's got magic
oh oh the the the armors
whatever all the avatars of the indians
just boring yeah boring make them look
fancy give them a headdress give them
some sparkles or something i want to see
more i want to see maybe the finale
maybe
maybe okay wow that's that's hot well
the internet's gonna be a blaze over
here yeah yeah that's gonna get that off
my
do we want like
monstrous
problematic oh yeah we talked about this
in our morning meeting this is what's
going to get you cancelled
okay no lukewarm takes here this is
okay so my not so hot take was the fact
of like
leila come on girl you had to have known
some was with this guy he was gone for
how long he did what for how long like
no that's impossible but my real
problematic take is
what did you do to save your little
brother oh
what did you do what did you actually do
because i mean we didn't see him drown
so did you kill him
like i i'm more so just wondering who
killed him how he died
and i kind of think it's you like like
like he said like eric vos said that
stephen king cave
is dark it's dark and i think the
secrets in there are darker so
king k
you're going with those in mardi gras
right if you find a little kid
okay i like both of those and before i
say the things that are going to get me
canceled i just want to quick plug
tomorrow we will be uh rehashing those
finale predictions and there'll be a
winner oh and a loser based on who got
the predictions the most accurate also
tomorrow we're probably going to talk
about this more before the episode's
over it's may the 4th and we have a very
very special may the fourth episode okay
star wars from the rooter to the tudor
that's right oh that's what the may the
fourth episode star wars gotcha gotcha
okay
but um
from the
from the ob to the wand okay we're going
star wars from the jar jar all the way
to your little binks oh oh and actually
as part of that that's a reminder um
there's going to be some cosplay on the
show tomorrow okay and some of my
co-hosts are going all out the costumes
that just admitted he's not going all
out i am not capable of going all out
okay uh way too lame not creative enough
but some of these people are very
talented and very committed they'll be
doing some cosplay me me you wonderful
audience members
send us tweet us a picture of you doing
your favorite star wars cosplay we'll be
sharing some of those uh photos during
the show okay use the
nr break room to get it uh to our
attention okay maybe maybe tag the new
rockstars account um we will have a fun
montage we'll get your pick of you as uh
doing your watto or here or uh brandon
does a great water voice could you just
do it
we're supposed to be having mandatory
fun sorry sorry that was mandatory plugs
uh this is mandatory fun um my
cancelable take yes
and this is i actually said this to
brandon before and he tried to back me
off of it okay but you know what i'm
committed to the [ __ ] oh here we go
the actor
who the french actor
who played
who played min
who in real life and this is tragic and
awful i don't like that everyone's
saying oh no he did he did die in real
life after filming wrapped i think it
was a skiing oh yeah that's terrible i i
feel sorry uh well wishes to his family
and his loved ones
um i thought he had a bad character
i thought the dialogue was pretty bad
and his scenes were pretty bad
um i i wouldn't put that on him okay now
while he's still alive he could maybe
take more classes or
she's got
that okay i did just make it work i
apologize so i apologize to you and your
legacy sir i did not even uh google what
your name was so that i could use it
you're making it worse
apologize to you and you know what that
could have been the show maybe they edit
around things maybe they wanted to do
reshoots but he wasn't i don't know but
those scenes were bad i love this show
i've really enjoyed this show those
things were some of my least favorite
can you said maybe if you were alive you
could take more acting class okay okay
that was too far i admit that i
i would like to rescind that that was
bad
nothing gets stricken from the record of
mandatory fun
everything is gospel everything is
written in stone uh i guess i'll do mine
but i have a feeling who's gonna win
this
really wish i had let that go last
my cancer will take is
not enough seeds in restaurants no i'm
just kidding
my cancer will take is i find steven
grant annoying i don't care about him or
he loves sweetheart stephen he's so cute
oh they better not make steven
permanently dead kill him
kill him
i don't want him back i don't need him
back oh he's singing
oh he's singing no oh he's singing kill
stephen grant never bring him back he's
a
wuss
he's a coward he's inept he can wear
that sweet-ass suit and he chooses not
to i don't want to do this i don't want
to be the moon knight it's the name of
the show
it's out in the title card well those
are all very cancelable
and chat right now on who has the most
cancelled takes uh
you know
these are these were some cancelable
takes i think uh it says 99
zach oh it is it is 67
that's running away with it right now
okay
i probably went too far jack is pulling
obama 2008 numbers right i feel like you
guys pulled away although uh
yesterday and in multiple test shows
jessica didn't label me the most
problematic members that's true i would
like to think
look at that
i think yeah with 61 it looks like i
think you got canceled for real people
might still be voting guys i don't know
we gotta wait until all the states come
in okay yeah you count everything stop
the count every vote is counted count
he's been canceled um speaking of things
you shouldn't cancel uh our good friends
over at the epic hero shop got some
great merch actually we are all rocking
some some merch from the epic hero shop
right now tommy's got a batman shirt
jessica has this great mephisto shirt
that we all enjoy brandon's got his tva
shirt and i've got a truster bro moving
company
they've got some cool merch over there
uh they've got that great trucker hat
yeah there it is from the thor trailer
they recreated that bad boy and you
could buy one for yourself they've got
some cool uh that wand division a
augmented reality shirt they've got that
fall into the multiverse shirt those
would be cool ones to order and where to
go see uh doctor strange versus madness
the wand division shirt if you wear like
3d glasses do they act crazy well it's
it's on your phone you look at it on
your phone all kinds of cool stuff
happens and this is 3d glasses you're my
cell phone and uh they don't yet have
their latest obsession shirt uh
available for purchase uh based on
multiverse of madness but it's coming
soon and if you don't think that shirt's
going to be hot as hell and a really
cool looking shirt yeah i got another
thing
you got another thing coming yeah i got
it i got another thing i got another
thing coming and it's that shirt in the
mail okay you got another thing coming
uh and you'll be getting all your shirts
in the mail because you ain't working
here tomorrow cause you're cancelled
we've never had people vote that fast
almost 700 people voted instantly to
cancel that get him out there
one million voices cried out at once
well i mean we're so pumped for the uh
moon night for the natalie tonight we
can't wait to be back here tomorrow to
talk about it when all of our questions
are answered and there's nothing else to
talk about with moon knight it'll be
beautiful uh but now we should really
talk about the other big thing this week
multiverse of madness
uh and the premiere was last night here
in los angeles and they had a london
premiere earlier uh i think over the
weekend or last week they flew from
london directly here well i don't think
it was like back to back a couple days
ago they had
then they had a premiere here last night
in los angeles our very own phone molina
got to go for a very fancy
interview i don't know
our very own eric
eric you don't know that person yeah
bleep that out leave that out
he left the show early to go what a jerk
there were a couple comments they're
like why don't you take your
your fellow cast members with you bro
eric only got
seven plus ones yeah that's right uh and
he likes to have three seats around
yeah
but at that premiere kevin feige was of
course there just dragging his money
bags down
down the red carpet when i saw him on
the red carpet i was like how can i trip
on my shoe and like fall into him and be
like um
just hand me money yeah yeah uh but he
did get asked about uh you know the
movie and all the events of the year and
he had a very interesting kind of
confirmation of some stuff we've been
thinking about how the multiverse got
broken so john if you'll roll that clip
let's see what old feige had to say but
how did you know that dr strange would
be the character to help take us through
the multiverse loki and sylvie did
something at the end of that series that
sort of allowed all of this to to be
possible he who remains is gone and that
allowed a spell to go wrong in
spider-man no way home which leads to
the entire multiverse going quite mad in
in this yeah
was able to so yeah so because this is
something we've theorized that the
channel you know if we were interviewing
kevin we'd be like yeah yeah we know we
want deeper stuff we want deeper stuff
uh but i love this idea that the id that
because he who remains is now dead uh
he's not there to control the timeline
anymore and so because of that doctor
strange spell
goes awry because of peter parker doctor
strange gets a lot of bad
bad rap for that spell going on bad but
peter parker keep your mouth shut okay
yeah peter piper no you're wrong uh
but i i do love this idea that if he
whoever remains was still around that
spell starts to go bad the tva shows up
and is like nope zap zap zap all fixed
immediately right but now uh because he
who remains is gone and we see the
multiverse starting to split and crack
uh that spell was allowed to happen and
caused this what is probably like a
branch timeline to the main mcu i think
because of all this weird stuff that's
going on uh i think that's kind of
fascinating and i love that kevin just
kind of confirms it and it's like yeah
he doesn't
know all the theories we kind of had
after
watching this clip was like oh okay you
he he immediately was like nope it's
already it was out there it was out
there but it's like yeah but we had so
many wild theories that this kind of uh
toned down for us now we know where
we're going uh and also he's allowed to
say whatever he wants yeah yeah yeah
that's true it's like no one he can't
who
who's gonna get mad at kevin fighting
yeah 30 writers cell phones just started
ringing immediately and saying we got to
change everything
but that leaves room for a lot of stuff
to go down yeah and it kind of puts it
in an interesting point in the timeline
right because all that he who remains
stuff exists beyond time all the tv
stuff is outside of time so the idea
that it does have a place in a physical
timeline that our tiny human brains can
understand uh it's fascinating and i
really like that uh and i think it's
gonna be very cool
i can't wait to see this movie uh philip
and eric both enjoyed it yeah the things
to say about it so are you saying kang
will be in this movie or are you
thinking
i mean
i am mom
and dad and mom will be in mom uh uh i
don't know i think
i think we won't necessarily see him i
think this is kind of like the end of
okay a lot of this like multiverse stuff
in a way in the beginning of like the
next stages of it this is gonna i think
there's gonna be some sort of revolu
resolution to all these multiverses or
some sort of new rule set in this film
uh and then we'll see kang have more of
a presence later on
and all the other things that come out
after kind of like the the first however
many times we saw thanos was just little
snippets little post-credit scenes right
not like
we found out after the film was over oh
the real puppet master of that villain
was thanos right but it wasn't actively
thanos during the film like maybe kang
is a little bit of that now right i also
don't be so nice to each other i don't
trust him where was this niceness when i
was getting canceled dancing
why are you looking like that hang on
yeah
it's when you go back to your smiley
face
no you were canceled during
mandatory fun playing the graphic
stop making a point
there it is
it's
a great big show john worked really hard
on these graphics we might as well play
them as much as we can the graphics are
uh but eric eric is actually going to
have a whole video about this tomorrow
oh beautiful up on the channel and also
his he's he's going to put up a
spoiler-free review of multiverse of
madness yeah
and you know we'll have lots of
multiverse and madness content over the
weekend that will have tons of spoilers
so make sure you you watch the movie
before you watch those videos and don't
be adding us don't be in our mention yes
and you know this always comes up about
around big releases we do our best the
first uh several days of a big film
coming out not to put spoilers in the
title not to put spoilers in the
thumbnail so that if you just happen to
see it wreck in your recommended videos
you don't get spoiled just from looking
but if you go clicking on videos on the
new rockstars channel after friday
things will get spoiled for it yeah okay
so just put those in your watch later
folder okay come back check us out on
monday or tuesday whenever after you've
watched it but know that we will be
there will be a post-credit scene video
on friday will be the full movie
breakdown on saturday okay eric will
begin those videos with spoiler warnings
but
uh we'll do our best not to spoil
anything in the thumbnail and we're
gonna do a break room on friday and
we're not gonna spoil it here in the
breakup even though we're gonna see the
movie on thursday thursday night yeah to
get parts i can't wait we're going to
i'm seeing it in imax
so much more footage to see 26 percent
what eric told us you can only watch his
video tomorrow if you watch the break
groups yeah yeah yeah
you have to watch both oh really quick
the who canceled votes came fully
through and it's 66
zach 19 tommy
brandon with a and then me with five
it's a reverse popularity contest
because we all know jessica is the most
popular
i am certainly the most expendable also
talk about an order 66.
take me out back and execute
we'll have more order 66's tomorrow on
our own special may 4th may the 4th
maybe we have the break room we have a
little time left in the show today uh so
why don't we answer some of your
questions yes you got any questions in
the chat just throw them in we'll get to
a couple i like a couple of super chats
yeah we got a couple good ones uh our
buddy danny shields just a shout out for
uh i might be mispronouncing this declan
chalvey's moon night art said we don't
get a lot of irish artists in comics and
his work is a direct influence on this
series he's the creator of mr knight
hey aaron go bro
uh oh danny boy yeah let's go
um mcdc wars he suggested ralph boner is
quicksilver sent by professor x yes i
love the idea that professor x is like
go in go into the hex yeah but just be
ralph boner no they probably were like
can you can you go undercover and
definitely quicksilver would be like
yeah
let's draw special attention to michael
hamilton and even though he put go
raiders
on his camera i'll say this i like the
raiders bo jackson what a great player
no problem with the raiders we're
friendly to the raiders yeah the break
room is a raiders friendly telecast too
much football i don't like he put it in
he paid ten dollars i'm giving him his
ten bucks worth i'm telling him that
we're looking right now he's going to
see multiverse of madness and dolby
atmos on friday oh
you pass out after a couple minutes
because there's not enough oxygen i
don't know what dolby atmos is but
they're probably never going to sponsor
a video on the channel now no you know
what we have a good working relationship
with imax if you'd like to support the
channel come to an imax theater tell
them new rockstar sent you yeah yeah and
the usher will be like i don't know what
you're talking about please stop talking
to me uh but michael hamilton after
loving the raiders did say what cameos
other than the baldy in the hover chair
oh yeah do you think we're going to get
now this is
i don't want to i don't i don't want to
talk about it if you're out there you
know there's like terrible spoilers out
there right now specifically for who's
in the illuminati uh uh all i say is the
cameo i want the most is shatter star
okay
played by played by uh i think played by
uh jared let him give him another shot
give him another kick keep giving him
chances he's had too many bites of that
apple my man i mean he would look good
in the ponytail i think the two of the
two swords i want dazzler by taylor
swift remember that
oh yeah
i mean i want jubilee everyone knows
that
she she plays said woot i made it to
watch i hope to watch the break room is
what you're talking about and we're so
glad you're thank you she plays uh blade
showing up a little bit at a time would
be awesome yeah i love the little blades
he's up there in a million pieces where
is he he's up there over there he's up
here he's over there um
uh so chris jackson asked what is the
point of hot guy
in this phase when everything else has
been multiverse oriented okay
you know what i i like that question
because like as we've gotten more
cerebral more meta with like eternals
even like shang chi had some like kind
of dimension hopping stuff going on and
obviously multiverse madness we still
got to keep some ground level stuff
going on right some like defenders verse
some whatever and so i like that hawkeye
did not get supernatural really beyond
some like crazy pym arrows you know and
he is he's a natural human for all
intensive purposes he's like he's this
guy he's got really good he is a natural
human
yeah
and you know thor's resolution exists in
space you know uh bruce's resolution
exists with gamma and changing yes you
know uh steve's got to go through time
max resolution was the bottom of a steep
cliff oh
that's not my fault i didn't make her
jump oh we got two canceled people but
it's just nice to be like this guy who's
just earth oriented he's got family here
on earth earth he just wants to retire
you know he just wants to go to new york
with his family yeah
when you're a crowd i like that because
here's the thing the great part about
the mcu as it's like broadening us we're
getting way more content than ever
before with all these disney plus series
they could tell a lot of different kinds
of stories you know what i mean miss
marvel will let them tell stories they
haven't been able to tell yet some
teenage coming of age
puberty kind of stuff like mixed with
the superhero stuff that's awesome that
we haven't seen that story told yet you
know and hawkeye got to tell us stories
that otherwise we wouldn't get to see i
mean whoever thought we'd get major
subplots devoted to larping yeah um
you know what lots of different stories
daschle it looks like daschle's our
cameraman sorry and i'm staring him
directly in the eyes trying to read the
super chat speech behind him and i it
was love at first sight thank you
daschle uh
okay i realize it says please tell mike
i said i'm bringing bread to work on
saturday never mind
i was like
well
taylor mcfarlane he did say well i think
when i was blaming peter for the spell
going wrong he said not peter's fault
he's a kid the adult should have known
better peter's an adult he's 18 years
old yeah oh in canada he can fight wars
uh
oh 18 is still too young also the adult
told him to shut up and he wouldn't shut
up okay is it is it the amygdala is that
the part of the brain that doesn't
mature to you're like 20 you go function
yeah
okay dr thomas they're all lizard brains
until then everyone knows
you're all back here the fish is growing
i told you we're not we're not doing the
last part of the brain a preacher that's
why you suggest things to people in
sales we're not pushing
one for the team said five dollars to
hear those curses god am it spelled it
the way zac
i will say
i don't think the super chats go to the
tip jar i tried to explain it but i'm
gonna allow it and say that that five
dollars gets us to the one piece yes
cause i will say i was [ __ ] at
explaining the rules
my turn my turn
yeah i'm a stupid [ __ ]
that's not how that's supposed to go
wait what you said the courage i hope
nobody i hope no one in chat clips that
out and saves it for us to be able to
use whatever we want tell me what i
can't say you just said to me
tommy you got a curse oh yeah this dirty
[ __ ] says today's show was gucci to poop
zach you got any curses you can't
yeah i um
you know what i i really regret some of
the stuff i said on this show god damn
it
well that has been the break room for
today tuesday live from our own break
room again
tune in tomorrow yeah may the fourth
texas yeah hashtag in our break room
share your favorite star wars uh cosplay
maybe that cool merch maybe yes lego in
your house show us your show us show us
you standing in front of your uh lego
death star do whatever right like um
we're gonna be sharing a lot of those
images in tomorrow's show also
tomorrow's a huge huge episode wednesday
friday gonna be a big old episode too if
you're like us and you're watching uh dr
strange thursday night you're gonna want
to tune in friday even if you're not
watching doctor strange we won't be
spoiling it you'll still want to just
hear people vaguely talk around dr
strange right that'll be us and then
monday we'll we'll get knee deep into it
we'll do all this spoiler talk and
here's something the rest of them aren't
going to tell you you're excited for
wednesday and friday's show
thursday's going to make those look like
infants
you don't know what i'm going to do on
thursday but it's going to be
life-changing this show will never be
the same after what i do on thursday so
tune in that day too i think i don't
know if it's been already said but i'm
just going to reiterate may it is
tommy's day may 4th tommy is saying we
put tommy in charge of the episode so it
is gonna i mean
world famous princess leia cosplay on
tommy
some photos to share with my own cosplay
yeah i love it uh i love it and we love
all of you thank you so much for tuning
in today check out all the content on
the channel it's moon night week it's
multiverse of madness week we're having
lots of fun and tune in tomorrow for the
break room we'll be right here live from
our very own break room here at new
rockstars hq
so long everybody have a good day
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you